so next game groundhog play
nice name
1730 from
Great Britain and he plays
the best meerkat style with bishop F4
yes
player actually always plays this structure
against
that actually also
a very solid choice for black
and white a bit dopey
you can even do something
sometimes yes B3 is err weird move
because it weakens the squares a lot here
I'll take it right here
like that and now I hope also E6 and
bishop A3
ideally if it lets me play
a bit slowly but I would
like to keep the bishop here
white  yes often moves that are so slow
aha ok he does something
concrete
yes ok
and now are top grouping yes ok
okay I'll go straight to the C3
pawn it's just really weak
and now they're doing one plays
I thought back then just
yes  It's a bit uncomfortable for
white because he can't
think of it that well now, so somehow not
with C1, for example I can just
take aim because of the 4,
yes passively, but
maybe that was somehow necessary,
yes, it's possible, so now let's try
runners  A3
directly with the idea bishop B2
yes so yes then I take with the pawn
so that he doesn't
get any stupid tempies with knight E5
maybe C5 will come one day
he has to play very concretely now
loose B2 threatens
just not what he is  now to be
honest
knight Tom B1 should move knight D2
so C2
yes or this nice move but now
I can just
take the four because the two
complete four and knight the two
hangs the four
and C5 he can still play but
the central pawn
is still threatening  Bishop B2 yes that's right so
if he has such a check but what about
bishop B2
he sees that then actually
knight F3 or somehow like that
I can still check like that on E4 or C3
yes try some
desperate action
like that and  now A1 take it 7
I could then just go a ref 8
and not give him a tempo I'll do it
is probably the
safest method
so you could just take it yes
but
I don't think I can even
get the bishop cleverly up here now then  if I make
bishop C3
good then he
can of course also then he can also
here but then he still has to
give up the knight as well
so
simply so that
F3
you should never actually do anything
except queen
somehow on the diagonal A3 something
I'm just checkmate that  you have to
prevent it somehow better but
as a tempo yes the
queen may now depend on the four maybe
actually has no real field
for the queen
so and now there on F4 there should actually
be a exchange of ladies no
no otherwise
yes and then you have it straight away  much more
today
yes the problem here is the move really
B3 so after that white has to
be careful that he doesn't
get any real problems
he can just play two games
or queen B3 at least because of also
somehow with the one with a queen and the
pawns B2  Cover and then is actually
normal balanced position